Transcriber: Sevgi Gerçek Claes
Gözden geçirme: Eren Gokce
Merhaba, hepiniz hoş geldiniz.
Bugün size benim onlarca yıl önce
yaşadığım bir çelişkiyi
anlatarak başlamak istiyorum.
Üniversiteden önceki yıllarda
benim önümde iki yol vardı,
kendimi bir yol ayrımında hissettim:
Doktor olmak ya da mühendis olmak.
Eğer doktor olursam, belki bir hastayı
kurtaramam ve büyük bir vicdan azabı
hissederim diye korkarak,
mühendislik mesleğini seçtim.
Fakat daha sonrasında öğrendim ki,
aslında mühendislik mesleğinde
bir hata yaparak, yüzlerce,
binlerce kişiyi
aynı anda öldürebilirsiniz.
Yani sorumluluktan kaçmanın bir yolu
yok gerçekten.
Belki de bu sorumluluğa en güzel örnek,
2015 yılında İzmit Körfezi
geçiş köprüsünde yaşanan halat kopmasıdır.
Bu şantiyede kendini sorumlu hisseden
Japon mühendis Kishi,
köprüde intihar etmişti.
Bu hüzünlü hikâye,
sadece inşaat mühendislerinin köprülerde
riskli olduğunu göstermiyor elbette.
İnşaat mühendisliği İngilizce'de
'civil engineer',
yani medeniyet mühendisliğidir.
Medeniyetin altyapısıyla ilgili
burada gördüğünüz bütün yapıları
biz tasarlıyoruz ve inşa ediyoruz.
Hayatımızla nasıl iç içe olduğunu
size anlatmak için
belki bir örnek verebilirim.
Diyelim ki sabah kalktınız,
ilk yaptığınız şey yüzünüzü yıkamak.
Musluğu açtığınızda akan su, borulardan
inşaat mühendislerinin sayesinde geliyor.
İnşaat mühendislerinin yaptığı
barajlardan geliyor.
Daha sonra lavabodan giden kirli atık su,
yine kanalizasyon sistemiyle,
bizim sayemizde.
Daha sonra arabanıza bindiniz
ya da toplu taşıma.
İş yerinize giderken geçtiğiniz yolları
inşaat mühendisleri yapıyor.
Köprüler, tüneller, havalimanları,
kıyı liman ve iş yerinde çalıştığınız
tabii ki ofisler,
sonra tekrar evinize gelip
rahat yatağınızda yattığınız evler
elbette inşaat mühendisleri tarafından.
Ve işin ilginç tarafı,
inşaat mühendisliği,
insanlık kadar eski bir meslek.
İnsanlığın ilk yerleşimleri
yine Anadolu'da.
Bu da büyük bir rastlantı.
Göbeklitepe, bundan 12.000 yıl önce,
ilk inşaatın başladığı yer
ve bundan sonra belki muhtemelen
en eski inşaat planı da
M.Ö. 1800'lü yıllara geliyor.
Aynı yıllarda yaşayan
Babil Kralı Hammurabi'nin
sorumluluk ve vicdan üzerine
yasaları var.
Bunun 229. maddesi:
'inşa ettiği bina yıkılıp
sahibini öldürürse,
inşaatı yapan da öldürülür.'
Bir sonraki 230. madde:
'Eğer bina ev sahibinin çocuğunu öldürürse
'inşaatı yapanın çocuğu da öldürülür.'
Gördüğünüz gibi
sorumluluklarla iç içe bir meslek.
Maslow'un ihtiyaçlar hiyerarşisinde
arkamda gördüğünüz gibi
bir piramit var ve bu piramidin
aşağıdaki en geniş tabanlı kısmı
bizim en çok ihtiyacımız olan şey.
Bunların başında da
temel fizyolojik ihtiyaçlar
barınma, su, ulaşım,
güvenlik gibi konular geliyor ki
inşaat mühendisliği
bu konularla ilgili çalışmalar yapıyor.
Muhtemelen bilmediğiniz bir gerçek var,
Türkiye inşaat sektöründe son 10 yıldır
dünya ikincisi.
Birincisi Çin.
Bu benim için
bayağı etkileyici bir istatistik.
Bizim ülkemizdeki müteahhitler
dünyadaki en büyük 250 müteahhit arasında
44 tanesi Türk firması
ve 126 farklı ülkede
48 yılda 10.000 projenin toplam maliyeti
400 milyar dolardan fazla.
Ayrıca inşaat sektörü her dönemde
ülke ekonomisinin lokomotifi pozisyonunda.
O zaman şu soruyu sorabiliriz kendimize:
Nasıl oluyor da Türkiye'de depremlerde
bunca kayıplar yaşanabiliyor?
Bunun cevabı belki de bu fotoğrafta gizli.
Acaba aranızda cevabı görebilen var mı?
Bu cevaplara gelmeden önce
belki de şapkamızı çıkartıp önümüze koyup
ciddi ciddi düşünmemiz lazım.
Nerede hata yapıyoruz?
Sebeplere geleceğim
ama size birkaç bilgi vermek istiyorum.
Mesela 2004 yılında
bir Kurban Bayramı akşamı,
hiçbir deprem olmadan yıkılan
Zümrüt Apartmanı'nı
hepiniz hatırlıyorsunuzdur.
Kendi ağırlığı altında yıkıldı,
hâlâ davası devam ediyor.
Kolon kesildiğine dair bir bilgi var,
ama emin değiliz.
Eğer günümüze gelirsek
Elazığ depremi,
daha geçtiğimiz günlerde oldu.
Burada birçok bina görüyorsunuz,
ama bunlardan bir tanesi yıkılmış.
Acaba bu binanın
yıkılmasındaki sebep neydi?
Bunları size maddeler hâlinde anlatacağım,
ama birazcık depremlere bakalım.
Bu depremler nasıl oluşuyor,
niçin oluşuyor?
Anadolu, güneyden kuzeye doğru ilerleyen
Arap Plakası'nın sıkıştırmasıyla
batıya doğru hareket ediyor
ve bizim ülkemizde
iki büyük fay hattı var.
Kuzey Anadolu ve Doğu Anadolu
fay hatları.
Bunu hayal etmek için
parmaklarınızın arasında
bir limon çekirdeği
tuttuğunuzu düşünün.
Sıktığınız zaman nasıl fırlarsa,
Arap Plakası'nın çarpmasıyla Anadolu,
Ege'ye doğru hareket ediyor ve
senede 2,5 cm ilerliyor.
Bu, tırnağımızın büyüme hızına eşdeğer.
Aynı zamanda da sıkıştığı için
faylar arasında biriken enerji
deformasyonla birikiyor
ve birden kayıyor.
Kaydığı zaman depremler oluyor.
Sonra yine birikmeye başlıyor,
ta ki tekrar kayıncaya kadar.
AFAD'ın yakın zamanda açıkladığı
bilgiye göre
son 120 yıldır 13.000 deprem ülkemizde
olmuş, değişik büyüklüklerde.
86.000 vatandaşımız vefat etmiş
ve 603.000 yapı yıkılmış.
Artık biz buna bir yerde
dur demek zorundayız.
Yine büyük depremleri
harita üzerinde koyarsak
biraz önce söylediğim fay hatlarıyla
bunların üst üste bindiğini görüyorsunuz
Bu fay hatları üzerinde
Elazığ da var, İstanbul da var.
İstanbul aslında depremlere
çok da yabancı bir şehrimiz değil.
500'lü yıllardan beri Ayasofya'nın
hasar görmesinden,
1509'daki Küçük Kıyamet diye anılan
olaylara kadar,
her 350-300 yılda ya da
18 yıl aralıklı olan da
büyük depremler olmuş İstanbul'da.
1509'da ahşap binalara geçilmesi
Osmanlı tarafından düşünülmüş
ve buradan bizim gördüğümüze göre
depremlerin, bir sonraki depremin
büyüklüğü ve zamanını
şu anki bilimsel verilerle
elde edemiyoruz,
ama nerede olacağını biliyoruz.
Çünkü bu
Türkiye deprem tehlike haritasında
gördüğümüz kırmızı bölgeler
faylarla birleşiyorlar ve buralarda
deprem olacağını biliyoruz.
Bazı kişiler çıkıp
'şurada, fay hattı üzerinde deprem olacak'
derse, bu depremi önceden bilmek değil.
Biz bu bilgiye zaten sahibiz.
İstanbul'da 5,8 büyüklüğünde olan
yakın zamandaki deprem de
bize bunları hatırlattı.
Dilerseniz size birkaç
bilimsel bilgi vermek istiyorum.
Deprem büyüklükleri
ikişer ikişer arttığında
aslında ortaya çıkan enerji
bin kat artıyor.
Mesela 5,8 ile 7,8 arasında,
ya da 4 ile 6 büyüklük arasında
bin kat enerji farkı var.
7 büyüklüğündeki bir deprem,
20 milyar kg dinamitin patlamasına eşdeğer
enerji açığa çıkartıyor
ve bu mesela New York şehrinin
bir yıllık bütün ısınma ihtiyacını
karşılıyor.
İstanbul'da beklenen
7,2 ile 5,8 arasında da
bu logaritmik bağlantıyla
126 kat fark var.
Yani son deprem, bu beklenen 7,2'nin
aslında 126'da 1'ini açığa çıkarttı.
Şimdi bu fotoğrafa tekrar dönersek
belki size
birkaç kritik bilgi söyleyebilirim.
İnşaat mühendisi olarak,
neler en çok etkiliyor.
Öncelikle eski tasarım,
çünkü 1998, 2007 ve 2019
deprem yönetmelikleri,
geçmişteki büyük depremlerden öğrendiğimiz
verileri içeriyorlar
ve daha fazla deprem kuvvetine göre
tasarlamamızı istiyorlar.
Bundan önceki binalar
yaklaşık 4 kat daha düşük
deprem kuvvetlerine karşı tasarlanıyordu.
Yapısal müdahaleler, kolon kesme gibi,
bunlar etkili ve bana sorarsanız,
kiriş kolon bağlantılarındaki
etriye eksikliği de
son yönetmeliklerde bulunan
fakat eskiden bulunmayan bir etken.
Buradaki gördüğünüz
kolon ve kiriş bağlantıları
depremde eğer etriye yoksa
mafsallaşıyor
ve sanki bir kuklayı
iplerinden bıraktığınızda
binanın çökmesi gibi,
bina çöküyor.
Mesela arkamda bütün kolon kirişler güzel,
hiçbir hasar yok
ama düğüm noktaları patlamış ve
bütün bina yıkılmış.
Perde duvar bulunmaması başka bir eksiklik
genellikle eski binalarda.
Burada gördüğünüz gibi
sadece kolonlar var,
ama perde duvarlar daha uzun,
betonarme elemanlar ve
bunlar depreme, deprem sırasında
çok fazla yük taşıma kapasitesine sahip.
Yapı zemin etkileşimi,
çok önemli bir parametre.
İnsanlar binaları ayrı düşünüyorlar,
ama zemin ve bina bir bütündür.
Zayıf zeminlere yapılan binalar, gerçekten
daha kötü performans gösteriyorlar.
Eski yönetmeliklere uyan yeni binalar
ve alkali silika reaksiyonu,
donatıların paslanması,
yine örnek sayılabilir.
Son zamanlarda belki sizin de
çok duyduğunuz bir fıkra var.
Üç müteahhitin binaları çökmüş,
birisi 'vah gitti benim kumlarım,
'çakıllarım' diyormuş,
bir tanesi 'mahvoldum,
'gitti çimentolarım' diyormuş,
birisi de 'iyi ki donatı koymamışım,
'yoksa benim de donatılarım gidecekti'
demiş.
Tabii ki bu insan hayatı bizim için
çok önemli
ama bir diğer faktör de
yapıdaki düzensizlikler.
Binada biz
düzgün çerçeveler oluşturmak isteriz,
X ve Y yönlerinde, bu şekilde
gördüğünüz gibi,
birbirine binen kirişler ve
düzensiz bir taşıma sistemi de
hasara yol açabiliyor.
Peki ne yapacağız?
Yapabileceğimiz şeyler var.
Bunlardan birincisi,
binamız sağlam mı diye
araştırmamız lazım.
Bizim ODTÜ'de geliştirdiğimiz
anketvari birtakım ön eleme
kriterleri var.
Bunlara göre bina stoğunu
genel olarak çok riskli, az riskli
ayırt edebiliyoruz.
Güçlendirme ve
son yıllardaki sismik izolasyon,
bir alternatif.
Burada arkamda gördüğünüz iki yapı
aslında tümüyle aynı
ve aşağıdan aynı depreme maruz kalıyorlar.
Ama sağ taraftakinin altında
sismik izolasyon var.
Binayla zemin arasına
bir izolatör koyuyoruz ve
yer salladığında bina
havada asılı kalıyor.
Elazığ depremindeki devlet hastanesi de
bu şekilde izole edildiği için
hasar görmedi ve ayrıca
müzeler, tarihi yapılar, hastanelerde
bu uygulandığı zaman,
deprem sırasında hastalar
ya da kıymetli vazolar sallanmıyorlar ve
depremden hasar görmüyorlar.
Buna bir örnek,
yakın zamanda
benim danışmanlığını yaptığım
Batman'daki, Hasankeyf'teki
Zeynel Bey Türbesi'nin taşınması.
Türbe, depreme karşı çok zayıftı ve
Batman ikinci derece deprem bölgesi.
Yeni gittiği yerde
zaten kaldırdığımız için
onu sismik izolatörler üzerine koyduk
ve deprem olsa dahi artık
Zeynel Bey Türbesi hasar görmeyecek.
Ülkemizde depremler oluyor,
sadece biz mi bunlardan hasar görüyoruz?
Hayır.
Mesela Japonya'da 1995 yılında
olan 7,2 büyüklüğündeki depremde
6.500 kişi can verdi.
Bundan sadece 4,5 yıl sonra,
17 Ağutos 99 Depremi'ni belki
yaşayanlarınız vardır aramızda.
7,5 büyüklüğünde ve 18.000 vatandaşımızı
burada kaybettik.
Yine yakın zamanda daha küçük bir deprem,
6,8, ama 41 can aldı.
Biz artık bu büyüklükteki depremlerde
can kaybı vermememiz lazım.
Bina tasarımlarında
performansa dayalı olarak
orta hasar görmesi beklenebilir,
ama yıkılmaması lazım.
Büyük depremlerde yıkılmayan,
orta büyüklükteki depremlerde
az hasar gören binalar tasarlıyoruz.
Geçmişten beri bizim bildiğimiz
4 tane element vardır.
Bunlar toprak, hava,
su ve ateş.
Biz inşaat mühendislerinin başı
hepsiyle belada.
Buradaki toprak olarak belki
depremleri düşünebilirsiniz,
ama toprak kaymaları,
taş düşmeleri...
Su ile ilgili olarak seller,
büyük yağmurlar,
fırtınalar, hortumlar
ve belki tsunamiler.
Mesela Japonya'dan bir fotoğraf,
sular çekildekten sonra
koskoca gemi binanın üzerinde kalmış.
Ayrıca yanardağlar,
yine depreme sebep olabiliyor
ve büyük yangınlar.
Biliyorsunuz Avusturalya'da yakın zamanda
bütün bir kıta yanıyor.
Peki ne yapacağız?
Ben sizi umutsuzluğa
kaptırmak istemiyorum,
hatta tam tersine umutlarımız yüksek.
Gelişen teknolojiyle artık
elimizde çok daha güzel aletler var.
Bilgisayar simülasyonları sayesinde
her binanın her köşesinde
ne kadar kuvvet oluştuğunu biliyoruz ve
buna göre tasarımlarımızı
çok güzel yapıyoruz.
Yapısal sağlık izleme denilen bir teknikle
binalara sensörler takıyoruz.
Aynı bizim vücudumuzda olduğu gibi,
sensörler, binanın bir yerinde
sorun olduğunda hissediyorlar.
Mesela dizinizde bir sorun olduğunda
nasıl ağrıyorsa,
binanın bir köşesinde
eğer bir deformasyon, zorlanma varsa
biz artık onu hissedebiliyoruz.
Bir yerinde yangın çıktıysa,
bunu önceden fark edebiliyoruz.
Önümüzde bir sürü fırsatlar açılıyor:
Gelişen elektronik, yapay zekâ,
robotlar, akıllı ve zeki yapılara
yol açıyorlar
ve 21. yüzyılda daha çok göreceğiniz
sürdürülebilirlik kavramı var.
Çünkü kirli sanayi ve endüstri artık
dünyayı yaşanamaz hâle getirdi.
Giderek daha çok güneş enerjisi,
alternatif malzemeleri kullanacağız.
İnşaat mühendisliğinde de böyle.
Üstün, süper malzemeler buluyoruz.
Mesela nanokarbon tüpleri
siz de duymuşsunuzdur.
Karbonfiberler, çelikten 2-3 kat
daha kuvvetli.
Ve size yeni bir üstün,
süper malzemeden bahsedeceğim.
Bilmiyorum aranızda tahmin edeniniz
olabilecek mi.
Bu malzemeyi üretmek için
fabrikaya gerek yok.
Betondan 5 kat daha hafif,
çelikten 15 kat daha hafif,
tümüyle güneş enerjisi kullanılarak
üretiliyor.
Herhangi bir hammadde de vermenize
gerek yok.
Hammaddesini tümüyle havadan alıyor.
Tahmin edeniniz var mı?
Ahşap!
Tahta diyerek beşinci element de diyorlar.
Ahşap malzemeler gerçekten
havadaki karbondioksitin oksijenini atıp
karbonunu alıp, gövdesini oluşturuyor.
Beton kadar kuvvetli,
eğer ağırlıkla orantılarsanız
çelikle baş eden, çelikten
daha bile kuvvetli olan bir malzeme.
Osmanlı'da bahsetmiştik,
günümüzde Amerika'da ve Kanada'da
yapıların %95'i ahşaptan yapılıyor.
Ahşap kullanımında belki de yangına karşı
zayıf diye düşünebilirsiniz.
Size çok meşhur bir fotoğraf göstereceğim,
yangından sonra çekilmiş bir fotoğraf.
Burada gördüğünüz iki çelik eleman
600 dereceyi geçtiği zaman
yumuşak bir hamur kıvamına geliyor
ve taşıyıcılığını yitiriyor.
Burada gördüğünüz donatılar,
çöken döşemeye ait
ve onlar da taşınırlığını yitirmişler.
Ama şurada gördüğünüz,
ince de kalmış olsa, ahşap kiriş
yangında dışarıdan içeriye doğru
yanmasına rağmen
hâlâ taşıyıcılığını devam ettirebilmiş.
O yüzden, yangınlarda
binanın çökmemesi önemli,
belki ikiz kuleleri hatırlarsınız.
Ahşap bu açıdan da
faydalı bir malzeme.
21. yüzyılda biraz fütüristik
olaylardan bahsedeyim.
Artık binalarımız kendi enerjisini üretir
ve doğayla uyumlu hâle gelecekler
ve ileride uzaya gittiğimiz zaman da,
belki Mars'a yerleşmek mümkün,
Mars'taki binaları da yine
inşaat mühendisleri yapacaklar.
Sizi kil tabletten Mars'ta binalara kadar
bir yolculuğa çıkarttım.
Doktorlarla başladığımız
bu vicdan ve sorumluluk hissini
eğer hepimiz taşırsak,
aynı doktorlar gibi
biz de hayat kurtarabiliriz.
Mühendisler, idareciler, çiftçiler,
doğru kararları alırlarsa,
sorumluluk ve vicdan sahibi olurlarsa,
bunu sağlayabiliriz.
Bir inşaat ve aslında
medeniyet mühendisi olarak,
Hammurabi Yasası'ndan uzayda yaşamaya,
doğru teşhis edilen hastalıklardan,
depreme dayanıklı altyapıya kadar
her alanda
vicdanımızın ışığında, hepimizin
sorumluluklarını yerine
getirmesi umuduyla.
Teşekkür ederim!
(Alkış)
Sağ olun!